we don't know exactly what caused his
love love this a mysterious thing as we
know and how many plays have been
written about love poems or books the
person doesn't sleep he doesn't eat and
becomes fixated or obsessed with another
person when it gets as severe as a
disorder it's very debilitating
obsessions
our expert psychiatrist dr. Carol Berlin
explores obsession in the brain with the
help of the new Hulu original chance
obsession is when a person has
persistent thoughts about anything and
they keep thinking about it over and
over again as opposed to compulsions
which are actual behaviors where person
does something over and over again mine
keeps going back to Afghanistan and does
like this scale and of like this stops
let's say you have to arrange all the
spoons in your door in a certain way and
it takes you like three hours and then
punish yourself with thoughts like oh
I'm bad I did this wrong I did this
wrong I did this wrong and the person is
trying to fight it and they can't even
get out of the apartment I had one
patient who was obsessed with her
girlfriend and she kept going after her
so bridal mania is a little different
and might be more exciting because it
has a sexual erotic element which is
more exciting than arranging it spoons
in the Torah but
erotomania is when person fixates on
another person constant emails to the
person telephone calls stalking the
person dreaming about the person
Jacqueline Jacqueline Jacqueline they
could become depressed from it or the
person could be enraged so angry because
the erotic object doesn't return their
love he told me how it would be if I
tried to leave in any medical field if
you get very emotionally involved with
the patient won't be able to help the
person we can't step outside the
boundaries because people have done
these things and terrible results have
happened patients sometimes kill
themselves if the doctor starts hanging
out with them or trying to have sex with
them and the restrictions are very
severe I want to help you I'm trying to
help you I care about you
a lot of psychiatrists will go for
therapy I've had doctors come to me and
try to you know stop erotomania or stop
obsessive-compulsive disorder we want to
make sure we're okay we're dealing with
mental patients every day so some of us
are not okay maybe we don't start okay
or why do we go into the field in the
first place
familiar with the concept of the frozen
lake something you want so badly we'll
go out to the center of frozen lake to
reach it when the ice is this but you
won't see that
we're just at the beginning of learning
about the human mind some people you
know we could work on them for years and
we can't get rid of the obsessive
thoughts it's always a challenge to
figure out how to take care of them
you